اكثر من اربعه عقود اضطرت خلال هالحاجه
صيص ابو دوح ارتداء ملابس الرجال حتى تكسب
لقمه العيش والانفاق على ابنتها الوحيده
بعد وفاه زوجها هي سيده من صعيد مصر ظهرت
العامه في صوره رجل لتتجنب المضايقات في
مجتمع لا يقبل فيه البعض عمل المراه عملت
الحاجه سيصه في اعمال شاقه مثل حمل الطوب
مسح الاحذيه واليوم تعود قصتها للاضواء
هذه المره في ازمه مرتقبه الفنانه منى زكي
اعلنت نسيت شخصيه الحاجه سيسه في مسلسل
تحت النصايه بينما توقع جمهور تقدم
الفنانه روجينا نفس الدور في مسلسل سته
هوم بعد طرح البرومو للعمل المنتظر صدوره
في رمضان المقبل
انهم لم يطلبوا موافقتها وتطالب بمليون
جنيه مقابل محاكاه قصتها هددت حتى باللجوء
الى القضاء في حال عدم الرجوع اليها قبل
اطلاق الاعمال الفنيه هي اليوم معنا على
الهاتف لتروي وجهه نظرها
[موسيقى]
يمامه
اذا نذهب الى الاقصر
لنتعرف اكثر على ما حصل حق صيصه مرحبا بك
معنا في صباح العربيه اولا وثانيا في حد
توصل معاكي من عمل المسلسل من الفنانين
الممثلين انهم عايزين يعملوا شخصيتك في
المسلسل
حاجه صيصه
صباح الخير
اهلا وسهلا تفضلي يا حجه
اكيد في حد تواصل معك من
العاملين في المسلسل
والله يا بنت وحيده ليه سنتين معي
علي
وجه
ك
تمام التمام ولا سنتين
من الناس
بقول لك صلي على النبي
انا الان
منى زكي وشيرين تطلع بدو
ري على شان
المحكمه
لازم تكوني فخوره بنفسك ومبسوطه وفرحانه
انهم عايزين
يقلدوا شخصيتك في الحياه يحطوها في
المسلسل
اها
طب يا حجه
لو جاءت عندك الفنانه منى زكي او حد من
ابطال العمل ودار العمل وتكلموا معاكي
هتخففي العقوبه
حاجه صيصه موقفك ايه دلوقتي بس عايزين
نفهم انت عايزه ايه
عايزه يقول عندك
يا حجه تكلم معاكي هتعملي ايه هترضي في
حال اتكلم معاك حد من المسلسل وقالوا لك
يا حاجه احنا عايزين نقلد شخصيتك توافقي
ما توافقيش بكل الاحوال ما بتوافقيش
طب لو اتعرض عليك مبلغ مالي كبير يا حجه
انت مشكلتك مع الممثلين يعني عايزه حد
ثاني يمثل دورك ممثله ثانيه
الرئيس السيسي كرمك وقبلك يعني كل الناس
فخوره فيك باللي عملتيه كل حياتك انت ليه
ليه رافضه
الريس ينشره
ينشروا
وانشر عليه
الرئيس السيسي عبد الفتاح
يعني اللي عدت الى السطح دلوقتي يعني انت
ليه قررتي تلبسي لبس رجاله كل حياتي ههه
[تصفيق]
بس يا حاجه في كثير نسوان بموت زوجها
وتكمل حياتها والحياه تمشي وتروح تشتغل
وتظل لابسه لبس
نسوان انت ليه عملتي كده
فلوس كبيره لو رفعت الموضوع للقضاء
قالت لي كذا وكذا كله
طيب يا حاجه اذا في كل الاحوال
قلت قلت
ماشي
[موسيقى]
وربنا يوفقك
واعتقد قصدك روجينا مش الفنانه شيرين في
روجينا والفنانه منى زكي شكرا لك من
الاقصر الحجه